hey
Oh
look at you
brought him back here I did that still
kick wraps and cars impacts to where my
kids had these muhfuckas hager sounded
funnier to shun bad i'm here as the
pills that they have you when it left in
this ass the other kiss your brother
Batman we the ass hey let's talk about
the album and blue slide park I ran
through it one time having this to it
the whole thing I haven't digested it
yet you know I listen to it one time
through we got to it well it won't I
noticed that this album is kind of like
it's more it's kind of like a more
musical move over place yeah it's more
crossover I guess right because because
you know like I said I loved you for
your more you know you're trying to do a
statik selektah and all that kind of
started this album I didn't get a lot of
that on it there's some though there is
something like my world I'm are like on
the record i really love we playing last
night on my undergrad show with under
saw i love it yeah that's that's that's
the crazy miss Collins go yeah see I
mean here's my thing man like as much of
a like hip-hop a design as well you know
I also love you know the Beatles and and
sublime right red hot chili peppers and
and weezer and music yeah I'm saying I'm
like jazz I like soul music so my whole
thing is man is like look I could sit
here and pump out boom back hip hop all
day you ever see nothing that's nothing
like I could do like you know saying
like I'm working on that project to do
that and I could do that all day but I
want to push myself to see what I all
right honey one of his own I want to
make music and this is music that I like
that I love you know so um you know
there is that boom bap on there but
there's also some some other stuff too
so like how's the reception being i mean
i know your fans are gonna love of the
metal yeah if i don't do there's one
thing about you then i'm sure you know
any blog you go to if it's a mac miller
post there's so many haters ola it's
crazy it's crazy I think you might have
more hater than any other rapper I know
it's great though is it has that feel I
mean I mean it depends man like
something like there's some [__] you
know like I was a like I was reading
this allhiphop.com
review of my house I just mean I just
saw that was like 6.5 and ash did like
it was like for the review today wrote
you would have thought that they gave it
a zero out of ten my wish it was horrid
a little bit i read it i heard what they
say about i think they said some bout
the beats of like Shane right and it was
all like wild [__] and it's just like
man like just suck my dick you know I'm
saying for you like I don't like if you
really want to hate on the have them
that's cool but like I got people that
love it people to understand that but
then I wrote like I've read MTV's review
of bread you know and they got it like
they got it yeah I'm saying what I go is
probably is this is I mean like I said I
listened to it I got my like I have my
records and I liked in my rec sounds
like that's not the magnens to exactly
but there's a that's was like I was
talking enough to wonder about it and
and I was like what you think that with
me he was like I mean there's some
joints on there he was like there's some
joints that I love and some joints that
don't like but like that's what it you
know that's cool we see that the point
is is to try and mix it up put a bunch
of different types of music on there and
trying like I'm trying to like open kids
minds of you know which is cool cuz like
you just said man like you just
mentioned night water in this interview
and it's gonna go online and some kid is
a Magna or stand is going to Google
knife owner in and I'm hopefully with a
little brother fans yeah I'm saying like
but at the same time it's like like I
want to put out good music for listen to
you know and whether that be you know
your boom bap 90s influence music or
whether it be some some something that
sounds like the postal service of indie
music right now because like I I just
want to be like the center of all of
that you know like I want to be able to
to do that and that's what I was worried
about you know is I'm like man if I go
into here and make some like missed
calls like I love that song can i still
do this and it's like yeah because
there's people like me who like both of
that um how much how much hate did you
get to endeavor of by remix
College surprisingly none zero that's
what sort like I mean no no I mean
obviously there's some hay but I was
like so geeked about it but but see
that's my thing knows that i'm like like
i can go to like name one person has
done a record with besides preme that's
done a record with DJ premier and then
done a record with maroon 5 and
Christina you later like true not many
and that's what I'm trying to do though
because like I was talking to Jeff about
jazzy jeff about this and it was like
and I was talking I was after best day
ever came out which was like when I
started stepping into cross hook cross
over right and and I was talking to him
and I was expecting him to just like
hate that project but he was like he was
like nah man like that's the beautiful
thing about you like that's the great
thing about you is that is that you can
do both you know I'm saying like like I
can't sit here and do just boom back hip
hop all day every day and you know like
that's not how you're supposed to do it
man it's about all music and different
and you know it's just kind of trying to
tie all this together and show that
you're you're in d you know music you
know you're m83 type music is it that
far off from your other music you know
so I have to I have to commend you for
really playing guitar on stage I saw the
video you just playing guitar you did to
parking it right I'm Doug smashing the
weezer joint I saw that and I was like
man finally a rapper who plays guitar
and actually plays it because little
weight hahaha he's just like I don't
know what the hell he's doing I've had
it where were the Tarzan's ain't coming
from his guitar yeah I mean masai guys
do is get down right did you see me put
it behind my head and jam yeah no I
always it was though I was impressed I
was like okay yeah i mean that's that's
the thing like i've been playing guitar
for ever so and that's what I'm saying
like if I only did boom bap hip-hop I
wouldn't be being my real cell right you
know that just like I love all kinds of
music so that's a part of everything so
to be genuinely me which is what has
always been my point which has always
been my my thing is that I always want
all my fans like there's no character
that I created
Matt Mac you are you is me like that's
who I really am as a person solar so to
do to be genuine and be myself I gotta
do that I gotta bring guitar on stage
play thugz mansion but then play Oasis
muse and beautiful man beautiful hey so
uh we'll wrap it up man you got any
collabos coming up I know you've uh I
mean like you said you work with the
who's who of hip hop royalty as far as
you know cross us underground cats I
know I can't like dude I'm I'm so
blessed yeah that like you can never you
know I gotta say that the face to fax is
my joy I put that on the cornerstone
make things like yeah yeah sure dude the
face of facts join us so ill because me
and praying I came there like two in the
morning and we were like ready to just I
was like about to do a record with cream
and we SAT there and talked about music
until six and it hit six and I was like
here let's make them song man and he was
like Iowa scope Mather beat and we just
did I was like that's crazy ass to the
song with DJ from there like that for me
yeah I was like a little fan and then I
was like writing and i started my verse
off and i was like like when i first
started writing I was like writing some
super fan [__] like I was like like
writing about how happy I was to do a
record for me and I was like I can't
decide for yes I cut it down like one
line oh man but it's got anything else
my god you know you're kind of like on
the superstar status coming up right now
that's crazy man I know it is mad like
I'm a little like to be real I'm a
little nervous and worried about what
life is gonna be like in a little bit
you know after next week right when the
numbers are official but I'm excited you
know I'm ready to do this I'm ready to
make music forever and it's great to be
here blue slide park the album yeah go
copy man thank you for coming through my
dude thank you for having me man i was i
was hoping i would be through here when
i got to vegas man i was like i hope i
like has me so i got one of those cool
interviews that code for video and
everything man i'm in the last like two
weeks it's official i pretty much
why Robert is Bob hahaha I Yelawolf last
week and almost started a war between
right I thought oh my god you're trying
to start out i interviewed machine go go
yo man what's the white rapper beef man
everywhere listen or angry or beef right
now no there's no man hahaha i'm
positive i'm [__] hippie man I just
like I just like hanging out with people
in show and loves to everyone who
deserves love it's a good one man like i
said i saw you a rock the bells and I've
never seen you live and that [__] was
wild man yeah you got you should come to
the show coming tonight no coming it's
gonna be having crazy yeah it's gonna be
nuts I mean my whole thing is like this
like just on a final note to go off
because we could sit here and talk all
day yeah all night wow you have a you
down with OPP sticker that's no um my
whole thing is look man I'm full of love
you know that's that's what I am like I
got love for people all different types
of music everything from from you know
your grimy ass of underground cats to
your cleanest of top action around I
love music so every one that hates you
know just just to let them know they're
hanging on a 19 year old kid who's got
nothing but positivity and love in his
heart not how do you sleep at night you
[__] hahaha oh man I Oh shout out to
Mac Miller if this video comes out I did
not provide the alcohol he's [__]
lying he's reason hug take this man to
jail bro by miners were alcohol he's
like he's like a shut up no man thank
you mean you're a cool dude I can't we
see you tonight yeah it's going down
nice i park loose I park out now to like
heaven let's go bears everywhere